do you think because i think i think of
like a team like the lakers that have
lost a lot of their defensive
credibility this year that's what i'm
saying that's on broad man brian no
brian no man
bro you know what time it is man that's
all you sure what do you think you know
what time it is that's all you bro you
know who you could call shawty mellow
too they ain't just on braun i lied
mello that's all youtube man if y'all
always heard nothing about y'all uh
defensive issues and
and leadership veteran issues and all i
don't want to hear that out of them too
i was gonna ask you like as just from
someone who's close to you know brawn
and mello like you know and also as a
basketball guy what do you think is is
wrong with the lakers this year
[ __ ] some doing an interview with you
right now
that's the issue
she should be with them no i'm fine uh
now for real for real it it
i was playing but i'm kind of serious
like i really do feel like it's
something that's
i haven't been around the team to know
exactly what it is right but
to me they don't get down together like
i feel like they don't feel like they
hanging out like well i feel like they
traded away a lot of that right because
if you think of like
for sure but i mean
there was a time that during that calf
season that bron literally
ex stretched stressed the importance of
us all hanging out together
like i remember the was it the halloween
party with steph curry always do stuff
like that was it was it a steph curry
tombstone was that what it was i forget
what it was
it was something like that
it was like a warrior's tombstone or
something or one of the bronze halloween
parties i don't remember i was i was
yeah i don't remember that that's that's
[ __ ] good
but um
you so you so you you think it's just
the fact that they don't really get down
together like it just i don't think they
got to advance they haven't had a chance
yet you know what i'm saying like maybe
kobe and all this other stuff like it
just doesn't look like a bunch of guys
that have been hanging out
and
playing pick up against each other
enough you know what i'm saying it's
like they don't know how to all the way
get each other vibing and that's you
know once you add russell westbrook it
changes a huge thing do you think that
that was uh
do you think that that was the right i
don't think that was the right decision
at all i think that they would have
rather have had buddy healed and kept
alex caruso
because that's what works better it
works better for braun right but
you're also talking about
19 years in braun
yeah
i'm saying so it's like
um